[Music]
rizzoli and isles you and angie harmon
you have great chemistry terrific
chemistry it feels like you guys are
friends in real life and that's kind of
like a uh you know an old saying is oh
they're they're friends off camera too
but you guys really do seem like you get
along we do we do angie um angie and i
met first um
when we came together on the show i
didn't know her before and yeah we we
have fun on screen and off screen we're
very touchy feely we make the guys a
little uncomfortable and set because
we're kind of you know girly would joke
around a lot what do you mean touchy
feel let's talk about that
and then maybe let's act it out uh uh
well uh
no no what do you mean touchy feely like
i don't think about girl stuff like
girls do a lot of like you know like
boob slapping and stuff
i do we do we do yeah we're like
i've never i've seen girls hug but i
don't i've never seen
[Applause]
i've never i don't know what you're
talking about i've never seen that i'm
not that's
it's sort of like it's sort of like a
like an exclamation mark like oh stop it
and then you flick someone's tip
can i say that no oh no you can't say
that
you can't say that this show will never
air now
i've been i'm around my share of women
and i don't see any of that going on i
don't know totally happens it doesn't
happen here at your work you have a lot
of guys you guys like we have a lot of
girls here and i'm no we don't caress
each other's bottoms
you know what that you're thinking of
like there's a lot of no you're thinking
of like yes
in the nfl there's some butt slapping
nobody no guys here are like hey good
job on that camera swap
rob
no one's doing that so it's just our
show
yeah but i'm really intrigued by this i
want to come work on your show
you and angie are like great scene yeah
you know that's craziness
[Applause]
there is speculation you're taking it
too far now i never take anything too
far
this show should be called too far with
conan o'brien
there's actually speculation that your
characters and fans have brought this up
they make fan art and we talked earlier
in the show about fans that make art the
fans are convinced that you and angie
they like to create situations where you
two are lovers
yeah
i you know but you know what i listen we
have chemistry we look like very i think
it's just the two of us we look very
different and so for whatever reason
women who are straight yeah respond to
us they like our characters and then
women who are gay and men right whatever
they they sort of look at in a sexual
way well here's some of the fan art
we've got three pictures here you can
scroll right through they've made these
this is very i've got that in my room
and then keeps keep going there's this
one they made oh my god and then i like
this last one right here where they just
got you guys making out you know what
those are really good graphics actually
that's that's good they do a very good
job yeah so those are all fake okay um
they're actually i i was going to say
that they are thinking of calling our
show season for rizzoli on isles nice
would that work i'll watch every episode
frame by frame